Hi, welcome back.
Our goal for this class is to learn to use the foliage tool to populate our worlds in
a short amount of time.
So let's get started.
The foliage mode is a tool that allows you to quickly add lots of objects like trees,
bushes, rocks, or even cubes if you wanted to, to your scene by simply painting them
in.
Instead of placing hundreds and hundreds of single objects one by one, you can just paint
them in.
The foliage tool is incredibly optimized for rendering large number of objects.
It uses instance rendering, meaning that our GPU will draw a lot of copies of the same
mesh in a single draw call rather than processing each one of them individually.
Unreal environment artists commonly use the foliage tool to fill large areas with natural
details like vegetation or small rocks.
However, for hero assets that we will see up close, it's better to place those manually
for precise control.
The foliage mode is absolutely perfect for background decoration, but placing assets
by hand is still best if you have specific compositions in mind.
So let's jump into the engine and see this tool in action.
So first of all, let's create a quick landscape we can paint the foliage on.
I'm going to switch from selection mode to landscape.
Then down here, I just want to set the scale to 100, the section size to seven by seven
quads, so the smaller and the rest of it is all right as it is.
And then we can click on create.
Okay, now from landscape mode up here, let's switch to foliage mode.
Up here on our toolbar, we will find a few tools which will allow us to differently interact
with our painted foliage.
But by default, we're painting.
Well actually right now we wouldn't be able to paint anything because we have not specified
which assets we'd like to paint with.
But if we click on this button plus foliage, we can see that we have a few assets already
prepared at our disposal.
So we can click all three of them.
One, two, and three.
And their checkboxes will be ticked automatically.
This means that right now we would be painting with all the three assets.
But we could also just toggle one of them off if we wanted to just isolate the painting
with those two.
So if we hover over on landscape now, you will see this purple selection bulb.
And if we click anywhere, we will be able to paint our foliage, which is incredibly satisfying.
Now if we're not happy with whatever we painted, we can press shift on our keyboard and we would
be switching directly into the erase tool.
And then we can click anywhere we want to erase our foliage.
Now if we wanted to, we could also select each individual foliage asset we have painted
and then move it around.
We could also select all of them or deselect all of them.
We have a few other tools here at our disposal, but we won't get into them right now.
Now if we select any of our foliage assets, a few settings down here will be displayed.
You would be able to change the mesh that we want to be painting with this foliage asset,
the density, so how much of it we want to paint with a single brush stroke, the radius,
the scale and more.
And if you wanted to, you could also select multiple assets at once and then apply those
changes to all of them.
There is something I want to change down here and that's the mobility of our foliage.
Right now it's set to static, but we actually want to switch it to movable.
This way we'll make sure our foliage receives accurate indirect lighting and contributes
to the scene global illumination.
If we left the foliage too static with Lumen enabled, we could see some artifacts, so make
sure you switch the mobility to movable.
Now for foliage or translucent objects, Lumen can still struggle a little bit, especially
when they're placed in front of other translucent or objects that are highly emissive.
So make sure not to overlap them too much with other translucent objects, like the clouds
for example, because you might see some artifacts.
So unfortunately we won't dive any deeper than this into the foliage today, but you
can find some designated classes explaining how to use it on our educational platform.
So I'd encourage you to check them out if you're interested in learning more about it.
Now one last thing I wanted to mention is that if you're working in a pretty heavy environment,
you can also convert the specific foliage assets to Nanite.
So if we scroll up here, then select one asset, we can find the mesh that is assigned to it,
and then navigate to it in the content browser.
Now down here, if you right click on this specific asset, we can find up here Nanite,
and right now it's already enabled.
But this is something that you can check out if your performance start being impacted
with the amount of foliage you have added to your scene.
So I hope this little demo gave you an overall idea of how to work in foliage mode.
Let's switch back to the slides now to conclude this video.
Alright, that was it for this class, and at this link you can find other extensive documentation
and resources to learn more tips on adding foliage to your environment.
In the next lesson, we will take a look at profiling in Unreal Engine.
Have fun building your environments, and I'll see you soon.
Bye!